meinen kommunikationsverhalten ja
sowieso keine auskunft geben sagen ich
auch nicht viel dazu außer das was ich
schon mal gesagt habe dass ich will
gegen diese app zu setzen so diskutiert
gerade ganz deutschland die krone app
soll datenschutz mäßig okay sein
sogar der kritische chaos computer club
sagt da kann man nicht meckern und
corona ist nicht vorbei wie die neuesten
vorfälle von tönniesfleisch zeigen
die app wurde bisher acht millionen mal
heruntergeladen
das reicht noch nicht in umfragen sagen
sie werden die app nicht nutzen ja wohl
ein großes thema seit dienstag also ein
bisschen dicke rohr ist ein bisschen wie
kinder erstes mal zusammen da kriegt man
menschen dann geht man einsam
auseinander also kinder rückwärts quasi
erlebt und gelebt wie viel haben sie
mutter gelang aber natürlich noch lange
nicht genug meiner meinung nach ich
finde jeder sollte diese app runterladen
und wer das nicht macht ist unsozial
meiner meinung in rückstand und war ja
ja ich muss da doch du mich als frau so
klagen wenn ihr schon im sozial aber ich
sage ich würde diese app gern
herunterladen ich kann es nicht weil
mein handy oder mein betriebssystem zu
alt ist und das bringt mich auch schon
zu einer größten kritik an dieser app 22
millionen in deutschland menschen sind
60 oder älter
wenn ich mit meinem mann denn für keinen
namen nennen aber mit meinem relativ
neuen telefon von einer firma mit einer
frucht ist eine app herunterzuladen dann
müssen wir auch mal daran denken wie
erreichen wir alles nicht und diese
menschen bei sich zu tragen sei offen
dafür haben doch noch alle die menschen
die wir nicht erreichen sind ja die
risikogruppe also die menschen über 60
und plus das ist riesig und die sitzen
alleine opa heinz sitzt da und sagt was
ist eine pop ich nicht und sitzt noch
mit dem fernsehprogramm da das er mit
einem buntstift markieren über durch
diese generation und wir sind ja auch
nicht digital native also selbst wir
kennen ja auch noch das von früher wie
es war
und die werden alle nicht erreicht und
dann macht so eine app auch einfach
keinen sinn
aber wenn es dann sinn macht und lust
auf dein iphone 6 herunterladen kannst
ist es dann würdest du dann runterladen
ich würde so schenkt sie mir neues
telefon über mein gehalt wir dann gucken
jetzt war sofort runter laden aber es
macht eben auch nur sinn wenn alle sie
haben es wurde er mehrfach schon
irgendwie gesagt und dazu werden wir
niemals kommen ja also ich den hier ohne
kommunale die chronik also ich glaube
wir sind ja noch mitten in diesem
geschehen wir haben ja noch lange können
wir keinen haken dahinter machen leider
ja wir wissen auch noch gar nicht was
noch mal auf uns zukommen
das kann noch mal sein dass uns eine
ganz heftige welle was wir nicht wollen
und nicht hoffen uns noch mal erwischt
um langsam kriegt jeder dieses gefühl
das ist schon auch ich kann es nicht
mehr hören das thema ist doch schon so
gut wie vorbei das stimmt ja einfach
nicht wir sind mitten im geschehen und
ich glaube die korona app macht nur dann
sinn wenn sie sage ich mal gesetzlich
vorgegeben ist also wir müssen einen
ausweis haben reisen
da sind alle unsere daten drauf und
damit können auch nicht alle schreien
ich bin zu transparent was ist denn wenn
ich mein ausweis man verliere oder so so
ist es eben
wir haben bestimmte dinge wenn die ampel
rotes ist die rodung wenn sie grüne soße
grün
wir lernen dinge und es gibt gesetze
wenn man jetzt sagen würde
jeder muss eine krone app runterladen
dann haben wir sie auch alle und jeder
muss sorge tragen sie funktioniert dann
wird auch opa heinz geholfen weil dann
kommt jemand und stellt das für ihn ein
weil jedes auto doch nummernschild ja
also wir haben viele sachen entwickelt
über die jahre die uns irgendwie
auffindbar machen und die uns
kontrollieren die uns auch nicht
vielleicht so angenehm waren aber wenn
dieses eine ansage sein dass man die ja
als müssen sondern es müsste so weit
entwickelt sein dass man sagt wenn diese
app von jedem jetzt runter geladen wird
dann bringt sie uns wahnsinnig viel und
schützt uns dann müssen wir einsehen
dass wir sie herunterladen und dann wird
muss man eben auch gucken wie man das
mit seinem telefon hinbekommt in
irgendeiner form also bist du für eine
art pflicht wenn es also zu sagen wir so
wir sind noch am anfang
komplett in den chor ohne themen über
immer weiter zu überlegen wie gehen wir
mit der situation um die es ja noch
lange nicht vorbei also wenn diese app
so ausgereift ist dass man wirklich sagt
also diese app die kann einen großen
teil menschen schützen wenn sie alle
funktionieren vor allen dingen wir
müssen ja informationen in diesem 1
geben sie runterladen können wir jetzt
gleich nach der sendung alle aber das
nützt ja nichts solange ich nicht alle
infos würde mich schon ehrlich gesagt
hatte
gehen und er ja ich höre von vielen
leuten oder ich mache kein test von
corona dann sage ich warum nicht wenn
die jetzt rauskriegen dass ich gerade in
der sekunde corona habe kann ich nicht
mehr zur arbeit meine kinder müssten
wieder zu hause bleiben mein mann
arbeitet an einem projekt und die leute
wollen ich mag einen test haben wir sie
wissen wenn sie es jetzt erfahren müssen
sie ein garant am ende das unter
staatlichen zwang quasi stellen möchte
ich drücke das jetzt mal ganz deutlich
aus seine forderung also wir stellen
unter staatlichen zwang dass jemand eine
app haben muss für die du deine daten
und das ist ja auch das was die meisten
menschen unsicher macht wohin gehen hier
meine daten vollständig durch die wälder
und luftgewehr wurde ja hier gelobt also
die kritischsten sozusagen
datenschutzrechtlich haben ja kaum was
zu beanstanden gehabt das war ja
wirklich das spannende dass da sozusagen
alles auf dieser freiwilligkeit basiert
die natürlich auch immer tücken hat und
auf vertrauen auf vernunft basiert aber
ich finde das passt ganz gut auch zu der
ganzen sozusagen eindämmung der krone
herausforderung in deutschland mit der
weder verhältnismäßig im vergleich
weltweit bisher ganz gut gefahren sind
deswegen würde ich vor sozusagen nach
pflicht waren ich finde dass sozusagen
das letzte mittel in so einer kette am
ende und gucken wie entwickelt sich das
und dass das über sieben millionen
anspruch genommen haben aktiv ist ja
erstmal positiv zu verzeichnen war die
älteren menschen gesprochen dass das
endresultat sein
deswegen habe ich ein land nur dann wenn
es etwas nützt
und wenn etwas nützt das sagt ja das
wort da nützt es fassen und wir müssen
unsere kinder übrigens zur schule
bringen und wir müssen ganz viele dinge
in unserem leben machen
die sind schulpflichtig wenn man es böse
ausdruck sagt man das ist ein land
müssen die kinder zur schule
wir müssen den ganzen tag irgendwas und
ich finde wenn man sagt diese app
schützt leben das im größeren rahmen auf
die zukunft gesehen wenn es soweit ist
dann sollte es pflicht werden solange es
ja ein test ist dieser ganz vielleicht
helfen infektionsketten nach zu viel
aber letztendlich keine leben schützen
doch aber niedrigen erwartungen an
solche app solange wir nicht weiter
hinnehmen was getragen so lange
die abstände einhalten wird uns helfen
ist erst der zweite punkt ist natürlich
sind menschen verunsichert wohin gehen
meine daten und natürlich ist es ich
stimme war in vollkommener schwachsinn
sich auf facebook darüber zu beschweren
zu sagen ich mache mir sorgen und die
datensicherheit wer so etwas macht ist
verzeihung ein volltrottel weil facebook
schon recht muss endlich was meist nicht
so viel verständnis für diese leute die
immer angst um ihre daten haben also die
herzen tragen die kandidaten
ich sitze im restaurant gerade zurzeit
jedes mal wenn oder sitzt da kommt der
kernsatz entschuldigung bitte alle
ausfüllen ich sitze im flieger bitte
einmal aussehen
da ist alles die wollen wissen wie du
heißt wenn du geboren bist
eine komplette adresse und telefonnummer
versehen und eine gastronomie deine
adresse hat oder der gastronomie im
grunde genommen schon längst alles von
uns ja ich glaube mit datenmengen und
die so gar nicht ja auch wenn man so
will fassbares geld sind informationen
die und wenn du nicht das gefühl hast
die sind in sicherheit und das ist das
problem mit dieser app und das
misstrauen muss man den leuten auch mal
können dass sie sagen das ist mir ein
bisschen komisch und wenn wir das auch
noch als pflicht machen
und wir reden von wifi erkannter mit
derzeit 5000 erkrankte angehörige
millionen von tönnies zeigt ja der ganz
aktuell ist dass die noch nicht wirken
darum geht sich dass die app nicht wirkt
sondern dass wir immer noch das risiko
haben dass man sich mit corona infiziert
wir reden von über 600 menschen ja denn
auch angesteckt haben
und ich da gar nichts im weitern ihrer
sicht ansätze geben muss wo wir dieses
infektionsrisiko ein dem und dazu kann
auch eine app gehören das heißt ich
finde dass du das jetzt noch gar nicht
beantworten kannst weil wir dann genau
die familie kein zum tut dir die familie
jetzt leiht www gehst oder persönlich
mit um also in gold und meldung nicht
mehr gestern in berlin angereist und ich
habe überhaupt gar keine zeit gehabt
auch mal geschlagen zu lesen weil ich
gestern gedreht habe und ich bin jetzt
hier in der sendung gerade beim vorspann
habe ich ein paar bilder gesehen aber
vielleicht kannst du mich auf können so
ganz habe ich das noch nicht mitbekommen
bitteschön es ging eben darum dass in
dieser fleischfabrik über 600 menschen
infiziert worden sind
du hast ja gerade gefragt ob ihr die
familie leid tut also mir tun die
mitarbeiter leid das habe ich gefragt
weil sich eine familie kennen um eine
note ja nicht vor einleitung ist völlig
klar
aber ich wollte noch wissen wie sie
damit umgeht weil sie mit dieser
verbindung befreien also es ist ich
glaube es ist kein zufall dass es in der
fleischfabrik passiert ist denn es hat
sich sozusagen peinlicher
bedauerlicherweise für unser land zum
billiglohnsektor entwickelt dort die ihr
gehende bedingungen sind katastrophal
die videos gegengerade rum in den
kantinen auch wo man gar keinen
sicherheitsabstand einhalten kann
und wir haben eben über tierwohl
gesprochen wir müssen aber in dem
zusammenhang unbedingt auch über
menschen wohl sprechen und darüber dass
all diese mitarbeiter die jetzt erkrankt
sind die haben werkverträge
die sind meistens rumänischer herkunft
und da gibt es keine lohnfortzahlung und
ich finde es ganz schwierig wenn dann
noch so getan wird seitens der politiker
als wenn die rumänen auch noch daran
schuld wären und da sage ich da hat es
heute auch ein paar stimmen gegeben
deswegen will ich dass er nochmal genau
also wir können jetzt nicht so tun als
wenn das virus aus rumänien eingefahren
worden ist sondern das ist entstanden
auch die durch diese gene bedingung und
dafür ist der fleisch betrieb
verantwortlich und die landesbehörden
also die schuldfrage haben muss
sozusagen bei sich selber angesetzt
werden und nicht aber daran waren die
anderen schuld aber es zeigt eben wir
sind noch mit wir sind noch mittendrin
corona ist ganz aktuelle als jetzt
vielleicht auch alle tatsächlich wahr
haben wollen durch diese ganzen
lockerungen wir haben eine umfrage macht
bei instagram genau wie findet ihr die
app habt ihr die er braucht
heruntergeladen statements waren zum
beispiel gerne weil ich ein bisschen
sicherer leben kann dass anscheinend
vermittelt die korona app auch
sicherheit bei vielen klar und
mitzuhelfen das virus zu stoppen und
jeder sollte helfen corona zu bekämpfen
das waren so ein paar aussagen die sich
ziemlich oft wiederholt haben ich bin
sehr gespannt wie sich die app behaupten
wird die muss ich jetzt wohl wäre wenn
ihm nur zu dieser app wenn man die daten
nicht hergeben will also man beobachtet
immer wenn einer was einkaufen möchte
und dann kommt irgendwie im netz erst
mal alle möglichen daten da wird alles
durchgesagt man hauptsache man kommt den
dingen nach die man mag ob so ein
fitnessprogramm ist aber es jetzt ein
einkauf ist usw
der mensch stellt sich in so einem
moment eigentlich kaum an mit seinen
daten ja weil man ja sag hallo ihr
müsstet alle und so dann sind alle
wieder so aufgeregt also ich weiß es
nicht wieder was zusammen ist wir sind
alle schon sehr gläsern also buddhismus
nicht darüber aufregen dass wir
unsere daten noch weiter geben müssen
wie sehr das muss sich alles noch
bewähren
[Musik]